well today President Biden is expected
to announce a new 375 million dollar
military aid package for Ukraine while
at the G7 Summit in Japan Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski arrived in
Hiroshima this morning to attend the G7
he's expected to hold several separate
meetings including with President Biden
zielinski said the meetings with friends
and partners of Ukraine will help bring
peace closer Elizabeth Palmer has more
security around the Ukrainian
president's arrival was extremely tight
as his plane supplied by the French
government landed at Hiroshima airport
zielinski's star power is going to focus
Global attention on the G7 Leader's
unwavering support for Ukraine and even
before he touched down zielinski had got
one of the things he'd been asking for
F-16 fighter jets President Joe Biden
has approved the training of Ukrainian
Pilots to fly the us-made warplanes and
European allies are expected to supply
the aircraft from among stocks that they
already own
the G7 leaders released their joint
communique a day early presumably to
clear the decks for meetings with
President zielinski tomorrow the
communique sets out some ambitious
targets including International
regulations governing artificial
intelligence mechanisms to deal with
Chinese economic bullying and a
commitment to phasing out fossil fuels
by 2050.
for CBS Saturday morning Elizabeth
Palmer Hiroshima